okay thanks
all right so welcome everyone
Henry asked me to give a little bit of
an introduction to the next couple days
so today and tomorrow we're going to see
a number of talks around the complexity
of multiple contracted pool systems the
reason we chose that topic is because
it's one in which there's been a fair
amount of progress in the past few years
and so we thought we'd take a couple
days to give you an overview of first of
all what are the main results in the
urea what kind of techniques such as
self testing are important to get these
results and how the questions along
multiple interactive hooks connect two
questions in complexity theory or in
cryptography also in the mathematics and
in physics so we're going to hear about
all this today and tomorrow and so let
me hand it over to Alex so that you can
tell people about the question-answering
procedure and then and then introduce
the speaker and so welcome everyone and
for questions that I think two types of
attendees so I think the panelists they
can unmute themselves and ask the
question directly to the speaker and
people who are attendees and not
families you can just write your
question on the Q&A and I'll try to to
find the right pause for papery and
asked him the question and yeah I think
I think we can start now so today store
today you have three talks and the first
one who you will be given by penguin
yell on non-local banner games with
noise EPR States okay that this is the
these games are decidable so please
bring me
okay shouldn't start
yes please okay so thanks for the
introduction
and
and my talk is about the non-local
binary games with noisy EPS discs
decidable
okay and
okay first I could I go to do it to do
briefly go through this point I think
most of you already familiar with these
models
so these non-local games we have two
players play one play too and and
there's a third party referee and the
roughy draw a pair of questions under
summative solution and thus and tend to
do the play one in a player two
respectively as the players who know
communicate to each other but they are
supposed to reply answers a tepee and
that's a predicate which maps XY a b201
youngest and one is wing and they will
what we are interested is the highest
probability they the players can win
again
and we know that it actually it captures
many the complaints not many
optimization problems busy like like a
satisfy Brady or CSP on its promise and
it is now that computing is no Omega G
is and be how
Olivia thanks to this a famous PCPD
theater is known not only computing oh
my god Eva approximating Omega G to a
constant precision is np-hard
I know corner water we are you see is
another player players are all share the
pipe by product honesty
and actually in Calexico city we also
tell us do me this check let's go
straight but using convexity argument
windows are surely classical randomness
news reason I'm going Conicelli is sure
panic currencies and we are also
interested with the highest probability
they win the game
and this region usually recorded a
valuable game
and again what is a complexity of this
competing Amiga stodgy and I think all
of your enduring the recent release on
this big paper movie that that you have
approximately Omega starchy to a
constant procedure is re complete they
say it is as hard as deciding a hoarding
problem
alleged approval they even not even even
if you join recently the player only EPR
state is already I this is a strategy
they to decide the strategy they want to
compute a hottie process of the optimal
strategies the players only needle share
EPS they of course infinitely many
copies
okay another question we I tried we
tried our study it is okay is that how
the strategies for non-local games are
robust against noise
but we must be civically we could start
we start from this squish stuff on this
special case what happened if the shared
space between the players are noisy
epsps me neither if you ask in part they
have tiny deep rising noise I don't know
that we also study okay now would hoist
the probability if the player share and
copies of these noisy EPR stays and I've
even further text and goes to infinity
the other we considered such kind of
variable
I've got this this big paper they prove
excluded if absolutely zero that it is
undecidable to approximate this value to
a constant position
and we also know if this absolutely
sufficiently small is this absolutely
this noisy EPS data is still entangled
show you the pleasure in finally many
copies then the entanglement between the
two players are still tends to infinity
if you under any kind of using any
entanglement measure so so the inflation
will answer us study other strategies
are robust against the noise noise for
this short stays in the state are noisy
okay dispute use these two computer hot
in prophecy
you know this is all the main resort
they say we surely if any binary games
in the parish absolute oycp artists then
reserve the place I only need to share
so many copies of stay to achieve the
optimal value to a precision that are
any cheap precision data and these
copies is our explanation to the spice
of crusher's and a published Ganesha to
the Wang overall the precision and
hustle annoying so meaning that force is
known we can we have upper bound or the
commune stays there you trade just brute
force search all possible strategies or
the such games decidable
so of course we did answer the question
because the strategies used to for the
porting problems and on finally now here
we just paint rigorously a partially
progressed all these personal questions
and I choose that previously there are
also several results study agrees and
reason to contribute Amica starchy such
as like a context or games the kona
unique games and all the approaches are
using a virus converse optimization this
is a formula polarized all these games
stymie typing programs and UTS PPS over
to prove the alligator has a polynomial
time algorithm especial and here we
actually stimulate with it
we design a simulation which is to
stimulate the high in kind of strategy
by low in tango sturdy so it is has
nothing to do with our previous approach
okay so I'm going to give it a high
level of the proofs before going to pro
se we tried we try to answer about basic
question we're saying okay if the
players are provided with infinitely
many copies of this noisy EPs days what
kind of distribution and they join based
on one without communication
you before answering this question
Leakey let's take a step back as what
happened in the classical study the
classical studies say the players are
sharing in finally many temples drawing
for the same distribution say P and
without communication what distribution
can we join in Istanbul
and this poem is called no interactive
simulation of joy dissolution and it
Galatia has a long history
it tastes back to 1970s
but I suppose until very recently that
decidability of this problem was
resolved in a series of work using
boolean analysis ok the for people who
are not familiar universes EPC just
consider boolean functions and the
defining inner product and if you have
been a product considered as a human
space now you have the bases everything
and a job before all analysis on this
space
so that design so these people approve
disappearances you don't distinguish
these two cases the first case yes miss
disease I mean the uses and coffees and
there is the strategy which acting all
hang samples so that they have the
players can jointly sample distribution
to prime which is absolute close to kill
and for normal for any of if for any
strategy if you jointly acting all and
Kobes whatever distribution you join
assemble Union it will be to a virtual
Photon Q because we are acting all the
wheels so we need this for missile gap
and for people who are interested in the
boolean SSI I like to eat man this
amazing book by Roy I don't know if I
should
that without communication only and I
look operation what honest a second
after they generate and this problem was
called the local state transformation
and it was studied a powerful study by
Peggy and he came when necessary could
necessary condition for the players to
convert one copy of role to Sigma
exactly
and other than that there's not much as
there are not many other work studies
and these people actually prove that it
is decidable if the feel sharing
in finally many copies or noisy EPS days
and a target distribution is a binary
distribution
and to do this we need to already have
the Gemini's the boolean analysis to
amido operators and the Rhino operators
okay so let's go the next lesson but I
don't groovy let's say so initially the
players parents share and copies of
noisy EPR stays and this is huge and
this is playing wanna pray over tools
strategy and we need to construct new
strategy keep on keep on acting our
situation what you have the this new
strategy and original strategy that
perform thing
what I mean is the meaning that first we
needed me this travel requirement was
this be the this small dimension D
should be independent an issue yeah it
should be able to do customer to be
independent or to only depends on the
precision
so we didn't have it I was a sucker for
any egg first we need this new strategy
P prime Q prime to still be a POV on
that one so me the P prime P thank you
a fern clears lighter now so our
students like high levels of the groups
so apparently there's a problem stage
lights yeah which which light are you on
like what's the title
oh okay oh sorry
so there was some confusion then okay
sorry sir for that okay okay so this
news key of measurement P prime Q prime
surely you should meet these
requirements first the P prime Q prime
must be a valid measurement so means P
prime Q prime should be between 0 and
identity and I don't - is the
probability that player 1 output 1
should be same in both cases assist the
players I wish are sharing noisy EPR
state so the margin or bone styles are
complete the mixture so this is the this
is the probability the probability they
won out who won even for new strategy
and this is a original strategy and same
for player 2 and alpha we need also the
prayer probability that both players
output 1 should be almost same in both
cases
so this is the probability and the last
to be we only we also need the three
prongs only depends on P 2 prime only
depends on Q because if you apply this
to a non local games players have been
performed different strategies on people
improves
no we need say okay the this and is to
cut in new strategy to only a Python is
a regional strategy shouldn't depends on
Paul's time okay don't know just go to
them well we need to do analysis
automation operators so we need to pay
first we need choose a basis and a
natural choice of course for basis is
poly basis and we know that this is any
two by two matches it can be written as
a linear combination of poly matrices if
the if the matrices are omit there's all
the even these coefficients are real and
I would even consider lying or not even
and come and registers and the terrain
then you just take any pieces and
curvature and attend to all them value
forms a basis in this space and now we
consider this has a Fourier expansion of
the operator and we have this identity
we see the mission of this really a
square of this Priya coefficients is to
norm of T but here to noise we need to
normalize it so here we uses three paths
to represent and normalize P nan basis
basically it is defined here and this
number has P known the pretty send a
subpoena of authority first and it
increased with reception a basic long
arm is more than two laws more than
three knows no no it's like a reverse
order of regular optional
okay now I'm going to the construction
well because the construction of this
property to people in the area consists
of several steps first we need to first
timely smooth operators by applying
noise operators which also think this
annoying
this is noise operator is only used in
analysis including information we also
call it depolarizing channel so you will
really as a density operator and QB
stage at right be providing channel or I
read to you I mean the depositor know
visited maps identity to identity and
for all other party matches you just met
to multiply by a factor role so it
applies at deploy internal value okay so
now use all these Sigma s you multiplied
by ro to the weight of s this s Widow
versus number of non-zeros of this thing
s the line we can split by two parts
first part is that part of each key that
has the weight of s is small and the
other part the weight of s is large and
here we come this way we call it a high
degree but isn't loading we don't really
as a polynomial and we know the others
try to be part of the wave you shrink
exponentially so we can actually we can
just remove this part well circle star
we go note to identify the number of
high inferential coordinates here inflow
inflow in for inference of commodity I
to P is defined in this basically you
don't trace out the coordinate and
replace it by identity over to and in
velocity out to distance between this
new operator and repeat and if you
expanded you see free
clear coefficient you can see this
influence of internal P can be written
in this form we see the solution of all
square with boolean coefficients with as
is not 0
then you can be evil cousin what a total
influence if you saw me all if it was
all coordinates and you just got to
summation now you're doing something is
such that s is not zero and if P is no
degree I mean it's all this s reach the
number according in which are non zero
is upper bounded by degree of even your
peers so that you can upper bounded by
big loopy and and here then you apply
the passive are in equal identity you
guys this not to normal P and of for any
places PCP is a POV arm anyone so this
quantity is a bounded by one so total
influence is upper bounded by the demon
so now we know that the null operator
has a bounded degree so number of high
influential coordination should be
bounded so we get a point so that we can
have a we can about even number of
coordinates which are high in friendship
and the Romania or low inflation and the
next time we're gonna do some replace
all the magic faces element in these low
inferential coordinates by Gaussian
variables if it is Sigma 0 actually
placed by one if I know C we have Sigma
1 Sigma 2 Sigma 3 are they actually
placed by independent Gaussian variables
so we're going to do this to this
constitution and now we get a Reyno
operator which you have the points upon
a dimensional bodies if it has a lot of
Gaussian variables okay I know I gonna
do I know less than I we can rewrite
this T to learn operators now it is poly
dimension for this code for these
coefficients are functions or a lot of
caution values and other or this caution
well all these functions are
two polynomials and they do they are low
degree angle less than last time we go
we try a dimensionally capture for
emission reduction for this law degree
polynomials of Gaussian space which can
be used to used to reduce a number of
Gaussian variables now we get the power
in number of Gaussian variables and a
pound in number of matches important
batchi basis okay I know okay then this
is fun I should have functions on all of
the functions on Gaussian variables
actual also forms space which we
recorded which is Gaussian space and so
you can ascribe this function in the
leaf in the linear combination of all
these spaces and each other basically
spaces are these meet up amid
polynomials and exist because the
difference is in this caution space that
I mention are in finite for the weekend
with some actual welcome we can further
replace all these Gaussian variables by
magic pieces I did not get pounded
dimension fills your merriment okay so
that is summarize the whole construction
it actually respond either arbitrary
p.m. element we suppose appliers
routing the operator pilot deep rising
channel to each coordinate and then we
can P you are and then we split by two
power which have a low degree part and
high degree path and this high t-v
powder
the weight is exponentially small then
removing now you get a low degree or no
degree operator then we I'm fine
how did a number of high inferential
coordinates
and I will particular substitution
really place all this low in Finnish
methods magic bases in low inferential
coordinates by Gaussian variables and
that's we go to apply then we use a
dimensional reduction to reduce the
number of Gaussian variables and then
you know you get a bound in number of
Gaussian variables and a power found in
number of matching bases now in father's
replace all these Gaussian variables by
matching bases and that's how you get
pounding them how many dimensional
operators and of course here I you can
all the technical details of why this
works but it's just the also the whole
framework of the construction and okay
then where we okay well we need neither
assumptions or share states are noisy
and actually only it is only required in
a step one when you apply the smoothing
of when apply the deep rising channel
you won't meet or definitely climber you
must assume that the pre share space are
noisy okay here's a construction and the
controller so first step as smooth and
vessels of course nothing to get a low
degree and a regularization to get a
identified pound in number of high
invention coordinates and the private
subscription you have get pounded poly
number of many places and unbounded
number of cautions and they're using
dimensional reduction to reduce an arm
of caution now you get a pound in number
of matching pieces and a polynomial
caution and step five you replace all
this Gaussian parabolic and the United
pound number matching basis for me so
the final match is upon attentional
and the step one step through hardship
unit oh and the linear means and that
identity to identity as a selenium
levels so but it's not that complicated
I know then stuck to as you touch them
to anything you just find a form for
true founded or high pressure
coordinates the only difficulty is step
3 and step 5 we always use a substitute
when we place a pony by caution you can
train operators and we need to prove
that we need to round it to pee opium
Adam and we wanted to operate between
zero at anything so here you need a
roundy I know this warning isn't
nonlinear and we need Clues at this
rounding as it does not hurt operator
much before where we need a tiny various
bins of all and they're gonna have a
contract inequality and a stop loss is
kind of actually Trussell reverse of
step three so I'm just going to explain
the step three
who wants me to structure it I just
repeated so we have three operators I
have a pony number of high inflation
coordinates and Romania low in furniture
and a low your friendship coordinates
and bad [ __ ] bases replace with
independent Gaussian variables and every
Sigma 0 means identity eternally placed
by one even other poly matches there I
just replaced by Gaussian because this
no no we need because that we need
middle this big final right but first
does interest
item two three four because it is a
because the probability right so if
you're coming if I'm looking on ran
operator you need further take into
account of randomness from the course
here so you just wrote expectation which
overall the scores
and it not hard to verify that it I
don't - three for me and I don't find
all so easy but you can see the p2 you
only depends on P 1 you can cap it off
on P 100 and the Q to thank you one time
now the only issues about I don't one
because you are only crazy now you have
a Gaussian wherever you operator so and
so this p2 and q2 could be unbounded so
how so I don't want us not hold in
general and we need to screw that so
it's table where we prove that the
expectation of the distance between P 2
and a POV of alamos a small as same for
children and this is what we called a
corner invariance principle we just say
if you obtain as P 2 for this procedure
then you can prove that the normalized
r2 now P 2 and a POV of polymers the
expectation distance is small and
there's how to how you go to these that
was not really cause that how can we can
P do from P 1 we just received only
prints all it matches basis in low
influential coordinates by Gaussian
variables and here we footage of
multiplying each costume very good
reason under Sigma 0 jungbaek P 1 P 2
are of the same dimension feature for
technical pendants now another thing we
want to show that P 2 is close to a POV
element don't even know meet operator
what it is close into POV of alimony
busy you just look at all these other
eigenvalues if eigenvalues greater than
1 you don't increase by 1 if I can raise
more than 0 it'll decrease by 0 and keep
everything else unchanged and this is
the way you character it's closer to
pure be irrelevant so basically you
don't apply you want to apply this wrong
in map
to the r22 rapido I don't know be Senora
if p1 is a POV of any much reason even
if you are long longing them to py
snoopy one there even one in P 2 minus P
2 sir
the new to normalize to norm is small
unless fully expand this function so I
max minus X so it is just this function
looks like this so they say we don't
show that it even change then happy ones
you know that expectational trees lit up
she too should be close to zero okay now
our goal is to improve that if transit a
p10 their expectation of chase that a p2
is know how to do that yes I know to do
this we basically just you know how we
can a p2 from team one which basically
gently place all these low inferential
coordinates by Gaussian variable so we
got to use a hyper argument which are
replacing one coordinate by one
coordinate when I said let's define P is
the vine movie star found edge across
one's coordinator and P is really
praised edge across the ice coding and
if you can really because I we always we
say that if we Sigma 0 then I generally
placed by one and so P I and a PI plus 1
they have something good they share
something in common
I just want coordinates 0 like that what
it does it's country right so that is
that's a part is Q which is the edge
cross across one coordinate is 0 so GU
so P I know PA plus one share the common
term which is Q but of course P is
indifference all right and the peer
grants one has one is 125 are I pass
we know that the p0 we starting from p1
and we at the p2 does computer hunama hi
is the coordinate ice coordinate is the
part of P where I scored it is nonzero
but there are two non square actually
score is really it is a summation of
clear potential and we call that these
are changes I've coordinate or some
influence of as fournier's of t1 which
do we know it is small right we know
that all these we are just replacing all
this low your initial coordinate so go
so busily wants you
so basically become UPI nappy across one
misses both we close to Q but they are
that we the beta form different
directions I know you will then we want
to ship okay we use a happy argument
says that through the TI the peer class
one our this because if we have any on
PR now we know that we I guess I because
P and a PI plus 1 or how pretty close to
Q so just deviate a bit because of this
possible
so another choice we just apply the
Taylor expansion on this function
transit hub at Q but the issue is that
in zeta function is not this rules it is
actually there has first order
derivative and you know it has second
order derivative exceptional finite
points I think we cannot compute a third
order derivative so we need to introduce
so we're gonna use a probe a smooth
function which approximates it how it is
a lambda
no has they - it has a first order given
to you a second order derivative I've
learned all the derivative is because it
is stabbed for finite points and we are
going to prove that this theta lambda
but the P I and a P R plus 1 are closed
so okay and as I said we include that
same we only use apply the chain
expansion and all of now the function
that you are acting on purchases so we
need to use the national unity which is
generalization of regular derivative fun
aha space different here and this did
you leave also have a natural highlight
expansion all this is ok I know you can
do that but please but technology that
can expansion of this is quite heavy
kaliesha but anyway you can get it so
you get a first order second order third
order but because and because of this
non commutativity so the second order
you join you need these before the union
right on all possible patterns way but
because I know also because trace is
cyclic invariant so they only have to
pedal z2r 2r or to occupy if you aren't
you don't you to merge q2 here they
catch you ha ha but both order you have
one ha ha the second order yeah who else
I thought although you cannot have three
hours and same for here I know
ok then we can prove we prove that in
the first order actual matches and a
second order of the matrices B - Connie
B are same then the only issue is the
third order what all the terms of e we
are there and you can if you can upper
bound it by the three Norma so high
and then they trace our P do guys these
are you just strumming or coordinator
you got no you upper bounded trace theta
P to buy the semester of three gnomes to
recover we know that the normalized to
norm square R is as influence life
corneas or P which is small so we want
to make a use of these two uptown the
three known not as you know I know this
is what every you need a corner hyper
contractive iniquity it's not even known
as to don't write too long is more than
normalize all three norm but if R is low
degree that it means no large then three
non has still be upper bounded by two
number up to the fact that I totally
agree 320 grit where are we going to
compute this expectation trace or theta
I know is this upper bounded by the
summation of the three moms and okay
there you apply these hyper contrary
inequality to convert it a to number
here actually we need a stronger version
type of contract equality we need a
randomized right so we need type of
contrary any way for any operators but
anyway but we have a nice on actual
advice it is Majesty math here
I know as we said these closeted this to
norm of our is actually influence on T
so in summation different schedules
three half
you can take a half of this influence
I already replaced by maximum and we
know now we know that
every coordinate the inference is small
and here the total influence is upper
bounded by a degree so totally that we
can upper bounded by this is 130 degrees
found it
so we finally we prove that this is
wrong
okay I know this is not going to give ya
this green Australia and I wanted to
yourself directions and open problems
yeah I do the first is what about the
target of distributions are non finally
the difficulty the difficulty to explain
this framework to non-binary is because
for binary we actually didn't act all
working on one operator P one p of your
alimony and the other one just identity
minor this class so we can let me do
this rounding obviously but if you have
a non binary then you have a worker a
stickers or POV element and when you do
that wrong then you give you may have a
arbitrary sequence of amino operator are
you want to round it up you no need to
appeal via and this running will not do
not have closed form and then to do the
hello expansion of this will be much
more complicated right now we don't know
how to do it
you
analyze what happened if about a general
monastic games here the Manasa game is
is a pleasure in finally many copies of
a given state room plus emergency rates
the players okay that's emitted a
pre-shared stay between the players are
produced by some machine so this machine
can only produce specific or the several
types of condensate but you can run
these machines forever and they produce
as many copies as possible
then is this game called decide what and
offer we know that if the shirt stays a
PRA it is undecidable angle here we
conjecture actually we decide what if
the fish as they roll a noisy this is an
econ estate by incentivizing noise as
well
well such game would be decide one and
the father will also ask wonderful local
state transformations if cleaners are in
finally if finally many goes
what kind of by-product forest a
stigmata clean and between Joint Base
create without communication and this
can also be used to answer what about
the non-local games with founder
monsters and try to keep
and all these other conditions they will
have all the high dimensional corner
hybrid contractor inequality when I hear
the hypocritical country we are assuming
it is a Gaussian noise EDP our state so
every registers of stagnation or - so
what happened - what did I share stays
noisy maximally entangled state with
high dimensional we we don't know how to
delete it because we don't know how to
believe simply because the hyper
contractive in the quarry here only
Roquefort I mention too
and unless the multivariate economy
various principle these edges as I mean
is where we start really we want to
expand the binary trees to non binary
case
yeah and authorities that we know
attention we know that in quantum
information theory there a lot of the
many many it's time set of quantities
like corner channel capacities regulars
I recognized entangle measure ona
information compress me essential
so the question can we use is brain work
- who's completed illative computability
all these qualities and why now we now
these quantities are known to be
computable
and the last is real the Berean ever see
Jose is a way he's amazing some Chinese
it has a lot of applications in Congress
city and agrees like classical
compressing theory every stone is
natural so can we find we have a more
application of quantities University in
common information theory and content
capacity who may be very interesting to
see okay that's it
thank you
so thanks Perry
so if people panelists have question
they can just ask it or people can just
like a normal Candace can just ask them
on the Q&A tab and let me start so you
have here an upper bound for some ticks
taps on right but do you know any game
that need asymptotically that amount of
entanglement like in order to achieve
the same distribution like do we have a
lot of I'm not quite sure cuz yeah I
think there was a paper by and we do
some kind of linear lower bound by some
other the other context but kind of
implies a linear lower bound for noisy
is this I see yeah they did but it is in
complete different context yeah okay
any other question
so yeah so if not so we can reconvene I
think in in half an hour I think I think
you have a lot of time for for a break
for coffee or for whatever is suitable
for your timezone and I think yeah you
can ask questions offline right now and
thank you paying way again per day talk